église notre dame de l'assomption
au xviiie siècle les églises sont les
premiers édifices monumentaux des
quartiers sur les dix construite à cette
époque il n'en subsiste que quatre
aujourd'hui dont celle de sainte marie
le terrain est donnée par anne mousse
une malgache qui compte parmi les
premiers habitants de sainte marie les
moins long les pierres de taille et les
bois de charpente par les fidèles la
maçonnerie et réalisé par des indiens et
la charpente est posée par des ouvriers
européens
érigé en 1754 notre dame de l'assomption
est la quatrième plus ancienne église du
guil ses murs ne possède pas de décor
architectural
la sobriété des élévations interrompu
par les ouvertures à linteau cintrée et
caractéristiques du style compagnie des
indes vers 1830 la façade est embellie
d'un portique couronné d'un fronton il
est supporté par deux élégantes colonnes
comme toutes les églises de la colonie
au xviiie siècle notre dame de
l'assomption possède un plan en croix
latine en 1935 un incendie détruit la
charpente d'origine et le clocher une
charpente métallique remplace l'ancienne
assemblage de bois bien que restaurer à
plusieurs reprises au xxème siècle
l'église notre dame de l'assomption a
gardé toute son authenticité en 2012
elle a été inscrite à l'inventaire
supplémentaire des monuments historiques